china negado hoy categóricamente que
rusia le haya pedido el envío de armas y
ha calificado esa noticia de
desinformación lo ha dicho el portavoz
del ministerio de exteriores en su rueda
de prensa diaria en respuesta a la
noticia que asegura que la desesperación
de rusia la empujaba a pedir el auxilio
chino en el campo de batalla esa noticia
exigen mucho escepticismo porque fue
filtrada por un funcionario
estadounidense en condiciones de
anonimato y sin aportar ni una sola
prueba esa petición real o no carece de
sentido porque el auxilio militar chino
nunca ha estado sobre la mesa y además
pekín se postulaba recientemente como
mediador así que no parece verosímil que
vaya a
proporcionar armas a uno de los bandos
la filtración llega en la víspera de la
reunión que va a mantener y ancce el
asesor nacional de seguridad chino con
su homólogo estadounidense jake sullivan
eeuu ya avanzado que pedirá a china que
no le envíe armas a rusia